so I am big-time in his and razón I love
it I love it sure one of my favorite
parts of the movie is that they sort of
give you license to be a little bit bad
one of the other lines is it's okay to
be a little bit bad
what percentage of Vin Diesel is a
little bit bad I think he got to be a
little bad and essentially if you're as
heartless if you're all good then you
only make whitewashed movies I always
felt I always felt like a real character
had cancer a real character had
complexity I was so excited to be a part
of this movie summer when the first one
came out last thirteen I was in the
industry yet and I watched it I saw the
inner cage and he was just a regular guy
doing crazy I was like that's me but a
male version
he's like a people's guy you know he
goes every Wednesday everybody loves
them in and you know I like Jim and it's
cool from what I've seen on social media
you guys all really genuinely like each
other yeah and I think VIN sort of
brings that 2sat like he's like it's not
fun who I do it you know meeting
everyone kind of came in a different
point because people were you know
coming off of other projects we did have
a costumer about a weekend two weeks in
and that was my house looked around I'm
just like are you serious like we really
are doing this film together this is
unbelievable it's more of a global
celebration of the cinema than it is
just this American Hollywood thing when
Nina Dobrev Ruby Rose you know Deepika
Donnie Yen Tony Jaa Michael Bisping
Chris Wu Rory McCann they all get out of
the car and they all come together to
meet van it was like one of the first
time they had everybody all together and
I kind of went like wow this is pretty
amazing it's a pretty good job done
girls
global domination and the cave
[Music]
you